several thousand people of trying to
flee at ukraine most of them going to
poland it has to be said but
some figures from various other nations
uh hungary saying it will accept a
number of refugees as the crisis
uh tends to escalate
there
but another word from the pope another
uh sentence uh he says those who make
war forget humanity
trust in the diabolic and perverse logic
of weapons so some strong words out of
the vatican this morning
these are
people
at one of the borders trying to get out
of ukraine this is the polish border as
people tried to head
west we were speaking weren't we to a
british national thomas jones
who
said he's very very sad to leave ukraine
and leave people behind but feels he has
no choice
the un
hcr said it estimated 120 000 had
already left
ukraine and the united nations warning 4
million or so
could try to flee if the war escalates
so that's the latest situation the pope
says his heart
we're getting some
various lines coming out of the vatican
now another uh
sentence from the pope pope francis
saying his heart is broken
by the war in ukraine god is with
peacemakers
not with those who use
violence